foreign
blockchain technology has been making
waves in the world of Finance but did
you know that it has the potential to
revolutionize many other Industries as
well hey everyone welcome back to our
Channel simply learn today we are going
to talk about the top 10 blockchain
projects that are changing the game in
the tech World these blockchain projects
go beyond just sending and receiving
cryptocurrencies and offer a range of
innovative services that can benefit
users so if you want more in-depth
approach to blockchain and to understand
how industry relevant projects are
designed check out our certification
program on blockchain in collaboration
with IIT kanpur this blockchain course
provides a high engagement learning
experience with real world blockchain
applications in fintech healthcare
Supply Chain management and many more
also do subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update or more such interesting topics
from Simply learn now first let's
understand the importance of blockchain
projects and how to create a blockchain
project blockchain developers are high
in demanding the software industry as a
result developing unique blockchain
project will set you apart from other
candidates other than that there is a
lot of room for innovation in this field
there are numerous unexplored
opportunities in this area that you can
explore also it has some prominent
reason for its significance like
decentralized structure now blockchain
projects are decentralized which means
that no single Central Authority or
individual controls them this means that
blockchain projects are open to anyone
and everyone
next is immutability blocking projects
are immutable because they are
decentralized which means that once
something is entered into the blockchain
it cannot be changed or removed without
access permissions
third is individual control of data
blockchain projects that enable
individuals to control that data will be
critical in the future by empowering
individuals control their data they can
choose how it is used and who can access
to it by changing the rules on their end
and next is tokenization tokenization is
critical in blockchain projects because
it allows for ownership without the need
for physical possession of an item or
asset it also allows people to Own Parts
of something but not the entire thing at
once making things like crowdfunding
much easier than they were before
tokenization
not talking about how to create a
blockchain project well to set up a
personal blockchain the first step is to
install ganache which provides a simple
and efficient way to run a blockchain
system once you have installed ganache
you can begin writing ethereum smart
contracts using the Truffle framework if
you prefer not to install truffle on
your local system an online option like
the remix IDE is available and to
connect to the blockchain and interact
with your smart contracts the next step
is to install the metamask room which
allows you to access your account and
manage your transactions now let's move
on to the list at number 10 is trusted
crowdfunding platform using a smart
contract this project is a blockchain
based crowdfunding platform that allows
you to raise funds for your project
securely and transparently
those who want to raise funds without
the need for centralized crowdfunding
platform with the trusted crowdfunding
platform you can you can set up a smart
contract that automatically releases
funds to your project when certain
conditions are met this ensures that
your backers funds are safe and that
your project is funded transparently and
securely by implementing a blockchain
based platform there is an opportunity
to bring about positive change now at
number nine is skill verification system
this project is a blockchain based
system that allows you to verify your
skills and credentials securely and
easily
perfect for those who want to showcase
their skills and expertise to potential
employers of clients skill verification
system uses decentralized consensus to
validate skills objectively users
anonymously judge examples or skills and
get rewarded for their work claims with
proof are verified by other members in
the same domain and either endorsed or
flagged based on consensus with the
skill verification system you can create
and manage your skill profile and share
it with others securely
number eight is peer-to-peer carpooling
this project is a decentralized
carpooling platform that allows you to
share rides with others securely and
easily it's perfect for those who want
to save money on transportation and
reduce their carbon footprint by
creating a smart contract Riders and
drivers can connect directly without the
need for intermediaries like Uber or Ola
these agencies having access to the data
of drivers and Riders raises privacy
concerns moving right sharing and Car
Hire to the blockchain can create a
secure and reliable carpooling system
with peer-to-peer car polling you can
find and share rides with people in a
community all while reducing traffic and
Emissions at number seven is digital
asset Marketplace this project is a
decentralized Marketplace that allows
you to buy and sell digital assets
securely and easily
it's perfect for those who want to trade
digital assets without the need for a
centralized exchange Dam acts as a
trusted intermediary between issuers and
investors of digital assets they offer
tools and services to facilitate
transactions building this requires
ethereum smart contracts written in
solidity and a web application with the
web3.js library to turn it into a
blockchain website with the digital
asset Marketplace you can buy and sell
digital assets such as domain names
websites and digital art all while
maintaining full control of your assets
6 we have fake product identification
system this project is a blockchain
based system that helps consumers
identify counterfeit products it's
perfect for those who want to ensure
that they are buying authentic products
with the fake product identification
system you can scan a product's QR and
verify its authenticity instantly by
linking a product's QR to a blockchain
you can store the product details and
generate QR code AS blocks in the
database scanning the QR code with a
smartphone can determine if the product
is genuine by comparing the code with
the blockchain database if the code
matches the customer receives a
notification that the product is
authentic otherwise they receive a
notification that the product is fake
this is a very interesting and useful
project idea and if you successfully
implement this then chances are the big
brands are going to knock at your
doorstep if if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
number five is transactions application
this project is a decentralized
application that allows you to send and
receive cryptocurrency transactions
securely and quickly it's perfect for
those who need to make cryptocurrency
transactions in the go while the
transaction application you can easily
send and receive cryptocurrencies from
your phone or computer without the need
for a centralized exchange at 4 we have
voting system now this project is a
secure and transparent voting system
that allows for fair and Democratic
elections
perfect organizations that needs to
conduct secure and transparent voting
while building the project ensure user
privacy by hiding their details and
using an ethereum address as the
identifier Additionally the system must
restrict individuals to a single board
and only allow eligible users to
participate the voting process should be
transparent adhering to all voting rules
and Counting of votes without any
possibility of fraud the application
will be developed using solidity with
the voting system you can ensure that
every vote is counted and the results
are accurate and transparent at number
three we have to do list app this
project is a decentralized to-do list
that allows you to create manage and
share your tasks securely
perfect for those who need to keep track
of their daily tasks when building a
to-do list application on a blockchain
the traditional web server and database
setup is replaced with the client's side
application that communicates directly
with the blockchain the applications
code is written as ethereum smart
contracts which contain the business
Logic for the to-do list and store the
to-do list item on the blockchain with
the to-do list app you can create tasks
set due dates and reminders and share
your list with others at number 2 we
have ether wallet this project is a
secure and easy to use wallet for
storing and managing your ether and
other erc20 tokens and stop for any
crypto investor with ether wallet you
can easily send and receive ether view
your transaction history and manage your
tokens all in one place the objective of
this project is to develop a smart
contract that can receive and transfer
ethos from one end to different
addresses although such contracts may
not have significant practical use they
are highly beneficial for learning
purposes by creating this ether wallet
project you will gain knowledge on how
to manage and modify either in a smart
contract this knowledge is crucial since
smart contracts have the capability to
facilitate monetary transactions which
is a fundamental aspect of their utility
and finally number one multicell this
project allows you to easily send
multiple cryptocurrency transactions at
once
those who need to make multiple payments
in one go if you need to send salaries
to employees consider using this
application which requires building an
ethereum smart contract you can use the
remix IDE and online development
environment that enables you to create a
smart contract using a solidity
programming language to build the
contract Define a function that takes an
array of addresses as input and include
a simple for Loop in the function to
process the payments with multisin you
can save time and reduce transaction
fees by badging your payments now let's
have a look at the essential factors
required for blockchain projects while
blockchain technology has gained a lot
of attention the sheer volume of
projects can make it challenging to
identify which ones are truly valuable
and worth investing time in so the first
factor is business liability
for a project to have a good chances of
success it must have a viable business
model this requires the company behind
the project to have a clear plan for
generating revenue and compensating
their employees
without a solid funding plan or a way to
pay workers the project is unlikely to
survive for long without external
financial support
second is ecosystem management we're
assessing new blockchain projects it's
important to consider how effectively
they manage their ecosystem of users
those who utilize their product or
service and engage with others online
the level of Engagement and activity
among these users can significantly
impact the Project's overall success
third is technical feasibility now the
technical feasibility of a blockchain
project is determined by its ability to
meet the requirements of its users and
functions as intended
involves ensuring that the Project's
source code is developed by skilled
programmers who can create a source and
private blockchain Network capable of
handling all necessary transactions and
there you have it the top 10 blockchain
projects that are changing the game
whether you are looking for a more
secure and transparent way to vote a
decentralized to-do list or or a way to
raise funds for your project blockchain
technology has got you covered so if you
like this video and found it informative
then please do give it a thumbs up and
share it with your friends also which
one of these projects are you most
excited about let us know in the comment
section below thank you for watching and
don't forget to subscribe for more
videos like this
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here